واشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
عبده ورسوله
صلى الله وسلم
عليه
تسليما كثيرا
اما بعد كين الرياض الصالحين
جمعه
يقول وعن اوس بن اوس رضي الله عنه قال قال
رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم ان من افضل
ايامكم يوم الجمعه
فاكثروا علي من الصلاه فيه فان صلاتكم
معروضه علي رواه ابو داوود باسناد صحيح
النووي رحمه الله
او رضي الله تعالى عنه
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
جمعه
صلاه
‏here
صلى الله عليه
‏and
valable because
we find
present so here for the prop
say
of the best of days the day of
so because
[Silence]
ج
‏time
صلى الله عليه وسلم
because of the best time of
that is also of the best of make
صلى الله عليه وسلم
جامع
[Silence]
it would be
‏All time what
time youl
have time
and what
‏make
time الله سبحانه وىص
عليه وسلم اذا تكفى
اذا تكفى
همك ويغفر ذنبك
[Silence]
الله
صلى الله عليه
‏and
beh الله سبحانه وى
any of سبحانه وى and as you time for
the sake of
دعاء الله
دعاء الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتعالى
[Silence]
ofر that lookd in the
صلى الله عليه وسلمعه
الفاء تحمل معنى السببيه كما اسلفنا كثيرا
صلاه
جمعه
صلى الله عليه وسلم
انك ميت وانهم ميت
‏in
level of existence which is generallyer
to as the grave which is time era of
existence that all enter into but is
specific to them that they are allow to
worship الله سبحانه وى in that of
existence we cann
‏die we enter the exe
of the grave ours are sealedcept
what we have behind however the props
and messengers they have been given by
to worship الله in in that level of
existence and there
the propetai
‏in order
them in order
for them
in
Allahasundstrued
people
‏not
if
will
notes
himself
from
making him someone
الله سبحانه وتعالى
قل لا املك لكم قل لا املك لنفسي نفعا ولا
ضرا الا ما شاء الله
‏tell them I do not for myself even any
good any bad except that it is from life
could helped us how much more so in
death
we worship الله and even if could
we would not to anyone other
mention
تفسير الطبري
ابراهيم عليه السلام
منجق
‏him and made out of
fire was so hot they to get him in the
midle of it so they put him on a
catapult
him in there and as he was on the
catapult moment away from being catapult
into the of this blaz
جبريل عليه السلام
ابراهيم عليه السلام
الله
ابراهيم عليه السلام حسبي الله ونعم
الوكيل
الله
سبحانه وتعالى
الله سبحانه وتالى
anyaves anyers
are we have bless
to
وجوده ان يجعلني وايا اياكم ممن يستمعون
القول فيتبعون احسنه والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا محمد